was darf die Polizei wer kontrolliert
sie und was passiert wenn Beamte zu weit
gehen wir sehen dann die Konsequenzen
für Sie aus
das kannst du dann noch von einem
Polizisten als er schon am Boden lag
noch gegen den Kopf getreten wurde
und es ist eine unglaublich schwierige
Sache juristisch Recht zu bekommen in so
einer Situation das Beste in
Anführungsstrichen ist in dem Fall noch
dass ich als sozusagen
auf dem Weg zu einer Demonstration gegen
die AFD Gary Thorsten Hanel im Mai 2021
in Merseburg in Sachsen-Anhalt mit
Polizeibeamten aneinander wir sind ruhig
auf diese Veranstaltung zugelaufen wir
wollten dort nur Freunde treffen danach
nach Hause fahren es war eigentlich
alles vorbei es war weder eine
aggressive Stimmung noch gabs Grund für
irgendjemanden aggressiv zu sein und
ohne irgendeine Vorankündigung habe ich
einen Schlag im Gesicht
der
in meiner Erinnerung wirklich sehr
heftig war also ich weiß dass mein Kopf
nach hinten geknallt ist also das war
ein völlig unerwartet man sieht sofort
wie quasi so ein wie so ein Rädchen oder
so ein Prozedere losgeht so also ich
habe nichts getan ich habe nichts
gemacht ein Polizist schlägt mich und
die bringen mich zu Boden und sofort
stehen alle drumherum und
ja stellen sich schützend vor die
Situation ohne für einen Moment zu
fragen was passiert hier eigentlich von
ich glaube ungefähr 15 oder 20
Polizisten der helmt in voller
Ausrüstung ich mittendrin Hände
gefesselt Arme nach oben gezogen Kopf
nach unten gedrückt bin ich dann
sozusagen 50 bis 100 Meter durch die
ja durch die Kundgebung durchgeführt
wurden und ich habe mich so gefühlt als
also also wären eigentlich nur schwer
Verbrecher oder Bombenleger oder was
weiß ich was was man da jetzt für eine
Bezeichnung für finden will behandelt
und es gab aus meiner Sicht überhaupt
keinen Grund dazu
eigentlich arbeitet Thorsten eng mit der
Polizei zusammen erst
rechtsextremismusexperte klärt über
rechte Strukturen auf berät Opfer seit
vielen Jahren engagiert er sich gegen
Gewalt und für die Stärkung der
Demokratie im Land umso enttäuschender
für ihn dass keiner der Beamten half die
Beamten die neben dem Beamten standen
müssen gesehen haben dass er zuerst
geschlagen hat aber keiner von denen hat
so reagiert als wäre ich das Opfer
sondern der Täter
Thorsten erstattet Anzeige gegen den
Polizeibeamten trotz Videomaterial und
Zeugenaussagen wird das Verfahren
eingestellt er muss sich sogar selbst
verteidigen Thorsten bekommt eine
Gegenanzeige wegen Widerstands gegen
Beamte gängige Praxis sagt sein Anwalt
Alexander Hoffmann tatsächlich ist es
aber so dass ich ganz häufig Leuten
abrate davon Strafanzeigen zu machen
weil der Erfolgsaussichten die
Möglichkeit wirklich nachzuweisen dass
das polizeiverhalten
rechtswidrig war sehr gering sind und
weil eigentlich immer wenn eine
Strafanzeige gegen Polizeibeamten kommt
eine Anzeige wegen Widerstand oder
tätigem Angriff kommt dass ein Opfer von
Polizeigewalt ohne Gegenanzeige
davonkommt habe der Anwalt bisher noch
nicht erlebt vor Gericht stehe dann die
Aussage der Beamten gegen die der Opfer
geglaubt würde in diesen Fällen fast
immer der Polizei
wir haben oft genug erlebt dass da
Aussagen von Polizeibeamten rauskommen
die mit dem Erlebten der betroffenen
Person gar nichts zu tun haben es gibt
manchmal Situationen das dritte gefilmt
haben und dann steht man vor Gericht und
zieht das kann nicht stimmen und
trotzdem Schrecken natürlich Gerichte
sehr stark davon zurück zu sagen das war
eine falsche Aussage einmal weil sie
natürlich im Alltag immer mit
Polizeibeamten zu tun haben zweitens
weil es ja trotzdem die Frage ist ob das
jetzt wirklich vorsätzlich falsch
ausgesagt war oder ob das vermischt wird
mit anderen Situationen insgesamt gibt
es aber schon so einen Kurs in den
gesagt wird
Polizeibeamten sollen im Wesentlichen
nicht Straftaten beschuldigt werden
kommt es zu Übergriffen durch die
Polizei haben diese für die Beamten
selten strafrechtliche Konsequenzen in
Sachsen-Anhalt wurde beispielsweise im
vergangenen Jahr gegen 101 Polizeibeamte
ermittelt in nur einem Fall kam es dabei
aber tatsächlich auch zu einem
Strafverfahren diese Zahlen bestätigen
sich auch im deutschlandweiten Vergleich
hier steht die Zahl der
Ermittlungsverfahren in den letzten
Jahren an gleichzeitig kommt es aber
2021 zu weniger Strafverfahren für die
Polizei Gewerkschaft Sachsen-Anhalt
liegt das nicht an den Beamten
Menschen das sagte ich vorhin schon sind
sensibler geworden Menschen lassen
deutlich schneller rechtsstaatlich
prüfen ob gegen sie möglicherweise
Gewalt angewendet worden ist der eben
nicht rechtskonform ist der
Polizeigewerkschaftler waren vor
einseitiger Betrachtung auch die Zahl
der Widerstände gegen Polizeibeamte
hätten sich seit 2018 um mehr als 50%
erhöht
auch hier in Halle kam es in den
vergangenen Jahren häufig zu
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen
Polizeibeamten und Demonstrierenden oft
ist Valentin hacken vom bündnishalle
gegen Rechts vor Ort dokumentiert
Übergriffe wie diesen 2021
[Musik]
das ist kein Einzelfall also wir sehen
immer wieder im Zusammenhang mit
Versammlungen dass es zu Polizeigewalt
kommt die aus unserer Sicht rechtlich
nicht zurechtfertigen ist also das
Einsatzmittel verwendet werden die
unangemessen sind für die jeweilige
Situation das betrifft insbesondere
tatsächlich Faust Schläger also das
Beamten und Beamte tatsächlich auf
Personen oft aus einem Gegenprotest
einschlagen als Journalist und
Versammlungsleiter von Demonstrationen
hat Valentin seit Jahren mit der Polizei
zu tun auch er weiß wie es ist von
Polizei Gewalt betroffen zu sein gerade
deshalb setzt er sich für Opfer ein und
berät Sie
ermutigen Menschen auch regelmäßig sich
an uns zu wenden damit wir im Zweifel
ihnen Anwältinnen und Anwälte vermitteln
können oder mit ihnen überlegen können
ob das ein Fall ist in dem eine Anzeige
sinnvoll sein kann wir empfehlen aber
nicht grundsätzlich anzuzeigen weil es
da aus unserer Sicht auch Risiken gibt
sondern wenn empfehlen wir Beratung zu
suchen und dann mit professioneller
Unterstützung zu überlegen was könnte
ich ein richtiges vor zu sein eine
pauschale Empfehlung Polizeigewalt
anzuzeigen halte ich für eine Gefährdung
der Betroffenen die häufigste Sorge
Betroffener dabei die Angst vor einer
Gegenanzeige durch die Polizei und dann
chancenlos zu sein vor Gericht meine
Erfahrung ist ich kenne in Halle keine
Fälle wo Menschen bisher erfolgreich
gegen polizeiweit vorgegangen sind
erfolgreich in dem Sinne dass dann
gerichtet das auch verurteilt hätten
Gewalt darf die Polizei anwenden aber
was ist wenn Beamte dabei die Kontrolle
verlieren wer kontrolliert dann die
Polizei zuständig ist die
Staatsanwaltschaft die ermittelt gegen
Polizeibeamte mit der Hilfe von
Polizeibeamten
2021 wurden rund 90% der Verdachtsfälle
wegen gewaltausübungen Aussetzung durch
Polizisten mangels hinreichend im
Tatverdacht von der Staatsanwaltschaft
eingestellt in nur 1,3% der Fälle kam es
zu einer Anklage
Hanna espin grau von der Universität
Frankfurt ist Co-Autorin einer
unabhängigen Studie zu Polizei Gewalt
einer ihrer Hauptkritikpunkte bei allen
anderen Straftaten sei die anklagequote
10 mal höher als bei Verfahren gegen
Polizisten
das Problem fängt aber schon früher an
nämlich bei den polizeilichen
Ermittlungen und dann in der Kopplung in
dem Vorverständnis was die
Staatsanwaltschaft durch diese
alltägliche Zusammenarbeit mit der
Polizei hat weil sich für die natürlich
die Polizei eigentlich als der
zuverlässiger arbeitspartnerin darstellt
wo es dann vielleicht auch leichter
fällt dem Glauben zu schenken was
polizeiliche Zeug in polizeilichen
Vernehmungen gesagt haben als die
Perspektive von den Betroffenen das ist
auch so eine Aussage die wir immer
wieder hören also ich vertraue dann
direkt Staatlichkeit ich glaube nicht
dass ein Staatsanwalt erstens das macht
und zweiten sich das leisten kann
praktisch so zu so so zu ermitteln wie
es ihnen gerade gut passt oder wie es
gerade ein Kollegen gut passt ich glaube
nicht dass es so sein wird ist ich kann
ich kann es nicht ausschließen dass man
möglicherweise das eine so werde das
andere so werdet aber im Grundsatz bin
ich der Meinung die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
in unserem Land funktioniert ganz gut
[Musik]
Tag X in Leipzig bei einer linken
Demonstration Anfang Juni eskaliert die
Situation
demonstrierende werfen Steine in
Richtung der Polizei die kesselt elf
stundenlang 1000 Personen ein unter
ihnen auch dutzende Minderjährige
unter den eingekesselten sind auch die
Kinder von Nancy denne und Rainer sie
sind Teil vom Bündnis Eltern gegen
Polizei Gewalt werfen den Beamten vor
rechtswidrige Gewalt gegen ihre Kinder
eingesetzt zu haben ich habe mein Sohn
noch nie so erlebt also er war so völlig
sowie unter Schock hat irgendwie so
also ich habe ihn noch nie so erlebt und
dann hat er mir einfach erzählt dass er
bei dem Kesseln bei dieser Demonstration
von so einem Polizisten so ins Gesicht
geschlagen worden ist mit so einem
Handschuh zum verstärkten Handschuh dass
das Bewusstsein verloren hat dass er
dann auf der Erde lag
das ist er dann nichts mehr weiß wusste
dass er dann nur noch weiß dass er dann
irgendwann zurückgezogen wurde von
irgendwie den Demonstranten so in die
hinter uns in den Kessel rein damit er
nicht weiter weil die Polizisten haben
irgendwie weit ständig weitergeschlagen
wurde und dann haben irgendwann die
Polizisten ihn da rausgeholt nur um ihn
dann hinter die erste Polizeiauto Kette
zu setzen und ihn da auch nur sitzen zu
lassen noch mal zwei Stunden oder sowas
und die auch die Demo Sanitäter wo einer
Arzt ist fragten kann er denn nicht mal
jetzt Krankenhaus und dann sagst du wohl
die Polizisten nee der ist nicht in
Lebensgefahr der bleibt jetzt hier mal
hier auch die 15-jährige Tochter von
Nancy war im Kessel und wurde wie alle
anderen wegen schweren Land
Friedensbruch angezeigt dass Ihr Kind an
den Ausschreitungen beteiligt war kann
sie für sich aber ausschließen
also man hofft auf die Gerechtigkeit für
die Kinder
weil die nichts gemacht haben und meine
Tochter zum Beispiel möchte gerne mal im
sozialen Bereich arbeiten die kommt
jetzt in die zehnte Klasse das ist ihr
Abschlussjahr und ich möchte gerne eine
Ausbildung im sozialen Bereich machen
und
ja natürlich ist da jetzt die Angst groß
dass sie das nicht kann weil sie
vielleicht negativ Eintrag im
polizeilich Führungszeugnis hat die
Eltern haben Anzeige erstattet an einen
positiven Ausgang für ihre Kinder
glauben sie aber nicht von ganz vielen
gehört da gibt's einfach nicht gegen
Anzeige dann bezeugen drei Polizisten
dass das ganz anders gewesen ist weil
die sind ja natürlich in allen die
kennen sich und dann sagt jeder Richter
hier drei Polizisten gegen drei
Demonstranten
also so also ich weiß nicht wie sowas
ausgeht ich fände es müsste in der
Polizei irgendeiner Art Fehlerkultur
entwickelt werden das muss eine
Ausbildung in der innerhalb der Polizei
geben dass sowas wie kursgeist bei
tatsächlichem wissen was sie machen
dürfen was nicht Polizei ist eine Kultur
und wie diese Polizei und wie es um
diese polizeikultur in Deutschland
bestellt ist
da habe ich jetzt sozusagen bin ich viel
skeptischer als vor diesen Ereignis die
Studie der Universität Frankfurt gibt
ihm recht laut Hanna espin grau kommen
auf einen angezeigten Fall sechs weitere
die nicht angezeigt werden viele
Betroffene wissen nicht an wen sie sich
bei Übergriffen wenden sollen außer an
die Polizei selbst die Forscherin
fordert daher eine unabhängige
Beschwerdestelle wie dann tatsächlich
aber solche externen ermittlungsstellen
Aussehen ist eigentlich eine sehr
komplexe Frage weil es da darum geht wer
arbeitet da wer hat die Kompetenzen dazu
arbeiten was dürften solche Stellen wie
zugänglich sind sind die da geht es dann
darum auf welchen Sprachen sind die
ansprechbar wo sitzen die wie sind die
erreichbar und das ist alles etwas wo
denke ich die Betroffenen Perspektive
auch wieder über Personen aus den
Communitys hereingeholt werden müsste um
solche Stellen richtig zu konzipieren in
einigen Bundesländern wie Sachsen-Anhalt
sind diese Beschwerdestellen aber dem
Innenministerium direkt unterstellt dort
sind oft auch Polizeibeamte tätig die
Unabhängigkeit sieht die Behörde
trotzdem als gewährleistet an auf
Nachfrage antwortet das Ministerium nur
schriftlich die zentrale
Beschwerdestelle ist räumlich bewusst in
Distanz zum Ministerium des Inneren
untergebracht zur weiteren Stärkung der
Neutralität der Bearbeitung wurde die
sonst übliche Zuordnung in die
Fachabteilung nicht vorgenommen auch
könne man zu dezentralen
Beschwerdestellen gehen so heißt es die
in Sachsen-Anhalt jedoch alle in
Polizeiinspektionen untergebracht sind
so fordern Betroffene und ihre Anwälte
dass es eine Abkopplung vom Ministerium
geben müssen
[Musik]
es ist nur ein geringer Anteil aller
Polizisten dem rechtswidrige Gewalt
vorgeworfen wird und trotzdem fordern
Opfer dass der manchmal falsch
verstandene chorgeist innerhalb der
Polizei aufgebrochen wird diese fehlende
Fehlerkultur also nicht
sagen zu können nicht überzeugend sagen
zu können
wir arbeiten Menschen die machen Fehler
und wenn sie Fehler machen dann müssen
sie genauso dafür gerade stehen wie
Menschen in anderen Jobs auch und das
ist das Problem und das finde ich
wichtig dass öffentlich und offen zu
benennen